This blog uses some nice
readable CSS class names
which refer to page structure rather
than the details of the style used.
For example, right up to
the top we see blog header and
a little further down this
banner area is called blog hero.
For blog header, we could just as
easily have used a header element and
modify our style sheet to refer to
the tag name instead of the class.
And then we would get the added benefit
of some extra semantic information for
assistive technology users.
We've highlighted four
other areas of this page
which have some class names suggestive
of the HTML sectioning elements
of the page we just learned about.
Your job is to fill in the appropriate
tag names just like we did with header.